so we've heard from David Bates about
the basic framework for thinking about
safety and quality today I am very
excited to have dr. Mudd geun-hye with
me mother is an epidemiologist he's a
physician he trained clinically in India
got his PhD from Berkeley and holds the
candidate chair in translational
epidemiology and global health and
directs the global health program at
McGill lots of titles but we're really
going to talk about today is quality and
TB so we're going to take this kind of
broad concept of quality and drill into
one of the most pressing ongoing
challenges in health for people around
the globe and that's tuberculosis so
mother thank you so much for doing this
I'm really excited that you're here
education thank you for having me um so
I'm going to jump right in and give
everybody a little background about
tuberculosis obviously TB has been with
us forever we've read about it in books
from thousands of years ago Egyptian
mummy Egyptian mummies that's right and
yet here we are
21st century and it's still with us
have we been making progress don't give
us a little state of play of TB where
are we with TB how much progress have we
made what's going on the tuberculosis
globally really important issue as she
so whenever I'd speak about no progress
in TB I show a slide of my grandfather
in India my mother's father even my
mother has no memory of him because he
died in his 20s of TB well I'm talking
about 75 80 years ago yeah and we know
that there was nothing much anybody
could have offered him yeah born in the
wrong era died so we could live with
that but to have one and a half eight
million people dying of TB today it's
just nuts because it's a curable
bacterial infection and to have that
many people dying even today basically
suggests that something is seriously off
in how TB is managed so there's no
rationale to lose someone because we
have the antibiotics the antibiotics are
bloody cheap so there is really no
reason
lose someone to TB today yeah a few
people with severe drug-resistant TB
that I understand so and most people are
not dying of them persistently well
that's what I said is the problem
primarily now that everybody who's dying
everybody was really sick just has
really highly drug-resistant TB is not a
major no no not at all aggressive sin t
v-- is a problem no doubt but it's
mostly localized in some parts of the
world and the majority of deaths are not
happening in red persistent cases
numerically the numbers are relatively
smaller 1.28 millions are not
drug-resistant the most of them are drug
sensitive TB they have somehow being
botched up they've either received care
too late or they not receive care at all
yeah or they've been just mismanaged in
the in the various sectors of health
care so the mortality is staggeringly
high and today actually the whu-oh says
TBS surpassed the the death burden of
HIV and malaria in other words TB kills
more people today than HIV and malaria
combined Wow
which is most recent statistics and
ranks in the top 10 causes of deaths in
the global burden of disease even today
by 2015 data so let me take a quick step
back and just unpack that a little bit
one question that I was going to ask you
is how does TB compared to these other
big killers malaria hiv/aids sounds like
we've made real progress with hiv/aids
and malaria are we making progress is TB
getting better but maybe just not
getting as better as faster oh so we're
the latest protection shows that in the
last 15 years TB deaths have declined by
about 20 percent okay it's not bad yeah
but you still are left with a residual
1.8 million deaths a year which means
it's a significant B words to start with
yeah secondly the numeric numbers of TB
new cases have gone up Wow so the year
before it was 9 plus million yeah last
world TB the for 2016 wh all increased
it to ten point four well that's today's
number the ten point four million cases
and 1.8 million deaths well and after
several for every year every year new
cases of TB as earlier and all more
half a million drug-resistant cases a
year is the current estimates God so in
some ways numerically it's worsened
compared to previous years which is the
opposite of what most infectious
diseases are trending to and part of it
is the fact that the numbers went up
because of India it's not that India has
suddenly discovered TB you're the
private sector in India it's nothing to
notify which as you know is a whole
another issue that will be in the
private sector does not even tell you
what they're managing the you end up
with this holes in the datasets are that
you really don't so the honest answer is
nobody in the world truly knows the true
magnitude of key being especially in
countries like India this is a whole
slew of non dots providers we are
managing TB were not being telling
anyone that then managing TB when they
start notifying the numbers jumped up
that what happened in India got it so 10
and a half million is almost surely an
underestimate
one Muslim the numbers have gone up not
because TB is number of TB cases is
exploding but we're actually starting to
identify and capture cases that have
been there before but we just didn't
only then know about that even that's
even true for drug-resistant all of
these decades we were under estimating
drug resistance because we never even
tested for it so using sputum smears
yeah which cannot detect that system
there are put the dominant diagnostic
tools for TB so now that we're starting
to use molecular tests like gene expert
suddenly we are seeing much more rife an
person and MDR assistance which again I
think is not because something suddenly
has exploded because we are more aware
by they're looking for it without it the
both the burden and the loss of life is
not primarily due to the underlying
disease itself the annoying disease of
course is problematic but we know how to
manage know how to manage it and the
second is that it's not that we have no
strategy for coverage it's not that we
have no ability to get people into care
that doesn't strike me as the dominant
problem and so what I'm hearing is that
the dominant problem really is in the
execution of what we do and how
comprehensively and effectively we do it
which is essentially another way of
saying the primary problem at least one
of the dominant problem
we don't have to rank it is quality yes